Royan toi tu vas encore te faire bananer
bon lui il va être avec moi mais je sais
pas il va supprimer bien là ça y est à
quel billet pour le séminaire bah oui
quel séminaire ah ouais ouais j'attends
la feuille de match là
parce que lui le problème que j'ai un
problème avec ce gars je dirais pas
invité je le vois je balader dans ma
maison en fait tranquille c'est un truc
de ouf ce mec je me lève le matin je le
vois le gars dans la piscine tranquille
c'est un truc de ouf donc je sais qu'il
sera là donc t'inquiète pas tu t'es
toujours invité je peux venir ou pas
ouais c'est chez toi mais viens seul ou
avec son plus simple il vient tout seul
là il est plus en moins un complice je
te cache pas que voilà c'est pas non
plus voilà non non mais sérieux ouais
j'ai négocié de venir seul donc d'accord
bon bah très bien Jean-Marie tu fais
quoi je suis complètement moi hors norme
je pars avec ma femme non on le sait
[Applaudissements]
ah le ringard quel horreur ta femme oui
oui et la grand-mère de ma femme
et moi hier je fais un jeu est-ce que ma
grand-mère est plus vieille que ma que
Daniel et tout tu veux je fais ça avec
tous mes potes non et en fait 4
grands-mères sur 5 sont plus jeunes que
Daniel ouais mais c'est la reine des
grands-mères pour moi
et on peut venir sans être invité
apparemment donc
il y a juste non mais juste il y a juste
un truc à l'entrée pour voilà pour que
s'il faut mon faut montrer
[Rires]
la grand-mère de ta mère c'est-à-dire la
grand-mère elle est pas loin de la
maison que j'ai loué donc on lui a pris
une chambre non non c'est la grand-mère
de qui la grand-mère de
donc voilà
[Rires]
attention
je vais faire un burn out
oui qu'est-ce qu'il y a Jean-Marie non
tout va bien en plus elle part à moi
avant donc je vais déjà être en vacances
un peu à Paris sans elle bah oui
de travailler non non mais pour
travailler c'est pas facile avec les
gosses là elle part avec les enfants
donc j'ai mes trois semaines de boulot
bah t'es tranquille
quand ta meuf n'est pas là tu travailles
mais bien sûr sinon c'est pas tellement
pratique avec les gosses avec le piano
et tout le bordel c'était trop sérieux
pour moi en fait
non mais je te dis oui mais je suis
fidèle quoi c'est ça le truc
est-ce qu'il vient de dire
tu viens de foot
en l'air la vie de Jean-Michel maire de
Guillaume j'entends
tu vois c'est un mot qui le déteste non
mais sérieux pas moi je suis célibataire
donc j'ai pas trop de mal être
finalement vous avez déjà été fidèle bah
oui il est arrivé comme tout le monde
ça arrive en 77 en mars 77
si vous avez un problème pendant ces
vacances c'est bien sûr vous pouvez
m'appeler à tout moment et vous
répondrez quand vous voulez n'importe
quoi pendant les vacances bien entendu
je savais que vous pouvez toujours
compter sur moi voilà donc appelez-moi
pendant les vacances bien entendu et
voilà vous laisserez un message
[Rires]
et moi il paraît depuis deux jours bah
non si le répondeur
[Applaudissements]